grâce à ce casque je peux venir piloter
mon smartphone grâce à la pensée alors
pas exactement grâce à la pensée mais
grâce à des mouvements fins musculaires
donc je viens bouger je fais deux fois
ça me fait play j'en fais deux fois ça
me fait pause je le fais trois fois ça
me fait video suivante surtout qui est
complètement dingue regardez là je suis
en pause je le fais deux fois je suis en
play je le fais trois fois et là je suis
sur la vidéo suivante ça c'est vachement
bien parce que cette innovation vous
permettra de venir piloter vos objets
connectés ça pourrait être des lunettes
ça pourrait être des lentilles
directement grâce à votre pensée alors
pas exactement la pensée mais en tout
cas des mouvements fin mais plus tard à
l'horizon peut-être 2025 allez savoir
grâce à la pensée je trouve ça vachement
bien la boîte c'est wesir innovation
française je vous invite à venir les
découvrir parce que moi personnellement
ça m'a bluffé et on le voit ici sur le
ces 1023 d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que vous aimeriez
vous venir piloter vos objets grâce à
des mouvements fins au niveau de votre
mâchoire